- [Voiceover] Currently
a local newspaper company
sells print subscriptions
for $9.30 a month
and has 2400 subscribers.
Based on a survey conducted, they expect
to lose 20 subscribers
for each 10 cent increase
from the current monthly
subscription price.
Alright, that's interest.
What should the newspaper company charge
for a monthly subscription
in order to maximize
the income, in order
to maximize the income,
from the print newspaper subscriptions?
So let's think a little
bit about their income.
It's actually their revenue,
how much money they're bringing in,
but I get what they're talking about.
So their income, let's
just say I for income.
It's going to be equal to
the number of subscribers
they have, so S for subscribers,
times the price per subscriber,
times the price per subscriber.
So that's going to be their income.
Now in the problem, they tell us that
the subscribers themselves are going
to be a function of price,
and that makes sense.
If your price goes up, you're going to
have fewer subscribers.
So they tell us right over here,
based on a survey
conducted, they expect to
lose 20 subscribers for
each 10 cent increase
from the current monthly
subscription price,
and the current monthly
subscription price is $9.30.
So let's see if we can write our number
of subscribers as a function of price.
So at the current price,
we have 2400 subscribers,
but we're going to lose 20 subscribers,
so lose, so I'm going to
subtract 20 subscribers
for every dime above $9.30.
So let's multiply that.
So if we just take our,
if we take P minus $9.30,
this would give us the
absolute price increase,
how much we've gone above $9.30,
and if we wanted to
figure out how many dimes
we are above $9.30, we could
just divide that by 10 cents.
So this part right over
here, this tells us
how many dimes above
our current price is P,
and then for every one of those dimes,
we're going to lose 20 subscribers.
So this is probably the most interesting
part of this problem.
This is kind of the crux of it.
How do you set up subscribers
as a function of price?
Cause once you do this,
you can then substitute
that in here and then you're going to have
income purely as a function of price.
Let me show you what I'm talking about.
So before I actually even do that,
let me simplify this a little bit.
So subscribers is going to be equal to
2400 and then let's see, 20
divided by 0.1 is gonna be
200 minus 200 times P minus $9.30,
and then we can distribute this 200,
so subscribers is going to be equal to
2400 minus 200P, and then
negative 200 times negative $9.30,
let's see that's going to be
two times $9.30 is $18.60,
so it's going to be $1800
and instead of $18.60,
it's going to be $1860.
So plus 1860, that's negative
200 times negative 9.3.
And now we can add.
We can add this to that
and we are going to get
the subscribers are going to
be equal to 2400 plus 1860.
If you add a thousand, you get to 3400,
and then you add 860, you get 240, 260,
so you get 4,260 minus 200P.
So we now have a simplified subscribers
as a function of price,
and now we can substitute
this expression in for S
in our original equation.
So if we do that, we
get income is equal to
instead of writing S, we
could write 4260 minus 200P
and then times P.
Now we can distribute this
P, and we're gonna get income
as a function of price is
4260P minus 200P squared.
So income as a function
of price is a quadratic,
and I actually like to write
my highest degree terms first,
so I'll just, income is equal
to, I'm just gonna swap these.
Negative 200P squared, plus 4260P,
so this is a quadratic.
And it is a downward opening quadratic.
We know that because the coefficient
on the second degree term is negative.
So this graph, I as a function of P,
so if this is the I
axis, that's the I axis,
and this is the P axis right over here.
We know that it's going to be,
so this is going to be the P axis,
we know it's going to be a
downward opening parabola,
and that's good because we
want to find the maximum point.
A downward opening parabola will
actually have a maximum point.
If it was upward opening, you'd be
able to find a minimum point,
but then there's no, it wouldn't be
bounded onto the up side.
So we need to figure out what price
gets us to this maximum point.
And this price, this is
going to be the vertex,
this is going to be the P coordinate
of the vertex of this parabola.
And let's just remind ourselves how
we can find the vertex of a parabola.
And there's multiple ways to do it.
You can find the roots.
You could find the X values that
make this function equal zero,
and then the vertex is going to be
halfway between those points.
That's one way to do it.
Another way to do it is you could say,
look if I have something of the form
I is equal to A P squared plus B P plus C.
Instead of writing Y
and X, I wrote I and P,
well the vertex is going
to be the coefficient,
the negative of this
coefficient, negative B,
over two times A.
That's going to be the P
coordinate of the vertex.
P equals that is going to be when you hit
the minimum or maximum point.
In this case, it's going
to be the maximum point.
So what's negative B?
B is this right over here,
so negative B is 4260,
and it's going to be over two A,
over two times negative 200.
So that's going be negative 400.
And so what is that going to be?
A negative divided by
negative is a positive.
This is going to be the same
thing as 426 divided by 40,
and let's see, can I simplify this?
Well let me just see.
This is going to be 40
goes into 426 ten times
with 26 left over.
So it's going to be 10 26/40,
or we could write this as,
this is going to be equal to 10 13/20,
and so if we wanted to write
that in terms of dollars,
cause we're talking about a price,
we would want to write this
in terms of hundredths,
so this is, this would be
the same thing as 10 and,
let's see if you multiply
the denominator by five,
you multiply the numerator by five,
10 65/100, which is the
same thing as $10.65.
And luckily, we see that
choice right over there.
Another way we could have done it is
we could figure out well
what are the P values
that get us to zero income,
and then the one that's
halfway in between
those two is going to be
where we hit our maximum.
Halfway between your two roots
are when you hit the maximum point,
so that's another way that you
could actually tackle that.
And you could do that just by
looking at this original one.
You could say well when
does this thing equal zero?
So you could say when does
4260P minus 200P squared
equal zero and since you
have no constant term,
you could just factor out a P,
so you say P times 4260
minus P is equal to zero,
so this is going to be
equal to zero either
when P equals zero, and that makes sense,
you're gonna have zero income
if you don't charge anything,
or if 4260 minus P is equal
to, oh let me be careful here,
I don't wanna, 4260 minus
200P is equal to zero,
so that's going to be equal to zero
either when P is equal to zero or when
4260 minus 200P is equal to zero.
This is when you don't charge anything,
you're obviously gonna have no income,
and this is when you charge so much
you're gonna lose all your subscribers,
and you'll have no income, but let's see.
If you wanna solve for, if
you add 200P to both sides,
you get 200P is equal to 4260.
Divide both sides by
200, you get P is equal
to 4260 over 200.
That's this price over here.
That's the price at which you
lose all your subscribers.
So your maximum point is gonna be
halfway in between these two,
halfway between zero and this,
halfway between zero and that.
Well halfway between zero and that,
is just gonna be half of this,
so your maximum point is going to be at
4260 over 400, which is exactly
what we figured out before.
That's $10.65.